foreign
[Music]
cast number eight and I want to thank
you for joining us today my name is John
Striker Meyer I am your host courtesy of
Jocko willink Productions and today
we're going to be focusing on uh one of
the Epic stories that occurred during
the eight-year secret war in Vietnam
fought by a man of SOG the Special
Forces Green Berets and their indigenous
troops and on this mission
we had 136 men
16 Green Berets 120 in business troops
that were assigned into deep into Laos
to take pressure off of a CIA operation
that was further west that was also
under uh great stress body NBA
and the team was inserted with Marine
Corps helicopters four helicopters
ch-53s that took them into the target
area and after insertion we'll talk a
little bit more about that but there is
one scene
on the first night or the morning of the
second day where the command post where
Captain Gene McCauley who was the
officer in charge of the operation was
with his senior Intelligence Officers
some indigenous troops and his medic
Gary Mike Rhodes and
what happened while they were there an
RPG a rifle propelled grenade was lost
into that site and were reading from Saw
Chronicles volume one
and the rocket exploded thus when the
shrapnel exploded
those of us who were injured didn't get
the full impact because the round had
gone past the men but hit trees and then
the shrapnel exploded backwards but
still with deadly force
and 45 years later after that rocket
explosion Rose had one lasting mental
image from it it's funny I can't
remember much about it except that all
of a sudden I was flying through the air
at some point while Airborne I looked up
and saw blue sky it was beautiful
and then I landed
later
Captain Gene McCauley told us Rose
showed us what he was made of that day
he immediately started to go to work on
the wounded because everyone in the CP
the command post at that time had
varying degrees of wounds
in fact Rose had a serious foot injury
somehow the shrapnel had
shredded his jungle Boot and cut open
his foot
somehow with that strapno he barely went
down and wrapped it around his feet his
foot I mean I'm sorry then he uses car
15 as a crutch and he began treating our
wounded so that's Captain G McCauley uh
on that mission on that day and we'll be
talking more about the mission but today
we are honored to have with us Gary
Michael Rose who was the only medic on
that mission that historic Mission Mike
wrote welcome to the show sir well thank
you
and you are again
my name is yeah Jose
so nice to be here John oh it's Mike
it's our pleasure to thank you for
taking the time and um
before we officially began recording you
were talking a little bit about how that
moment in time you're lucky because I
don't want to you you described it
better than I did you're explaining how
that round went off it picked you up in
three through the year and you're glad
to hit your foot instead of your head
well
obviously if you you if I'm looking up
and all I'm seeing is Blue Sky
it looks like I'm upside down I mean
just I and I can't tell you what the
configuration of my body was at that
point but that's all I could remember
it's just a break in the Trees of the
canopy and and I could see the blue sky
and I did hear this like a like that
sound when you put a stake on a barbecue
yes that was the sound of that hot piece
of metal going through my foot it was
your foot at that time sizzling and then
later on I got to thinking about it
you know how you do with hindsight you
know it's great you know 2020 right yeah
I was just thinking boy I'm glad
actually I was blown up that way instead
of head up because that could have been
my head
although it might have knocked some
sense into me I don't know indeed
so um this Mission because of the size
of it it was also unique in that when
the helicopters first went in they took
uh relatively heavy gunfire
and a lot of SOG missions if a
helicopter is going in
and they took gunfire they were
obviously compromised but on this
mission
your men continued on and on your
helicopter when you were you on the last
one that went in
um no I was with the I was with on with
Gene with Gene I remember standing uh
our um
our CCC sergeant major was standing next
to me he was going in with the ride I
guess
um
you know it it sounds funny and I'll
tell you this it it it's kind of now
that I think back I didn't think it
probably at the time but now that I
think it's kind of comforting that that
here's a guy that's willing to get on a
helicopter to go in there with you not
to stay but just the right end and then
try to get out and I can tell you we
were taking rounds from the time almost
we crossed the border because
when you hear rounds hitting the ch53 it
sounds like popcorn popping to me is
that right yeah in fact uh if you've
seen the movie
um
Saving Private Ryan sure and when they
first going in and the rounds hitting
the whole so those uh boats yeah it's
about
and I think Higgins boats and
helicopters were probably more or less
made
out of somewhat the same material I
think they were aluminum or whatever
and um they I might be wrong on that but
boy it sure sounded the same
but um it's comforting to know that you
know especially when we when the ship I
was on
when we landed we had I had to step over
a couple Mountain yards so technically
there were 120 going in going in
but when we when the helicopters left
they left with at least two mountain
yards that I know of now they were
injured but they they didn't pass away
that's our God for that yeah so they're
rude on the insertion which you know
they were wounded before we even hit the
ground yeah wow so it was an odd LZ
going in and uh
and I and I think the reason that unlike
most missions that would be considered
compromised and now you've got to
understand this is this is a 74 year old
person thinking about something that
happened 51 years ago most likely that
mission was to pull NBA troops off of
that CIA operations and they wanted us
on the ground
period indeed I mean it was it was uh it
short of being blown out of the sky I
guess we were going in yeah and although
that term wasn't used at the time
indeed now uh 51 years in retrospect
that was essentially could be called a
suicide mission going in that heavily
and that with that Target area well
some people you know
um yeah
you
right ruled a few helicopters in Vietnam
and you can you know how relatively
flimsy they are indeed
most previously I was riding in Huey's
yeah and this was a big helicopter it's
uh and it's the biggest in the uh our
helicopters area we just had it at that
time well the reason they got picked was
because they had the range sure could
have gone so deep in the layouts and the
the other and and that was also true why
we were using Marine Corps cobras
instead of army cobras because my
understanding now you have to understand
that I want to make this perfectly clear
sure
I would say 98 percent
of what I know about operation Tailwind
I have learned since 1998 which was
almost 30 years later indeed being told
by reading witness statements and
talking to people that aviators and
everything else so
uh because you were busy on the ground
patching up your accounts people that
were weren't you concerned about what's
going on around you and I'd say well
your folk you know you've got your
training as a medic you have to
understand something by the time I got
to Vietnam
I had been in the Army since at 19 and
I'm not 22 almost 23. yeah
and so
you are uh
you've got several years of training
plus I'd served a year in Thailand uh as
a medic in the 46 Special Forces company
working with Thai National Police and
Thai Army so I I learned a lot of things
in that year
so when I got to
Vietnam I was not combat experience but
I had a lot of you know
going in on helicopters I had other
things working in Thailand so uh you
you're well trained and I and I and I
will tell you the Army I don't think
giving the period of the time in history
I don't think the Army could have
trained me any better than it did
first off I don't think the the
technology
that we had they could have trained me
any better right and um and I think you
um
you're you're going in focused on what
you're responsible for
my task was basically you know I'm along
for the ride until somebody gets hurt
when they get hurt you're kick in the
gear yeah exactly and then you focus but
that doesn't mean you're ignoring what's
going on around you because obviously
I'm not right
but I'm not concerned about that machine
gun fire or that those rifles Fire or
the mortars coming in that's that's not
my concern that's what those other guys
the other 15 guys were concerned with
and the other 120 yeah well your food
alternates the other 119 because the one
one mountain yard was with me and that
was cooch and God bless
Ed yes I wish I wish we could find him
yeah I love that little guy and just for
a side note Koosh was
your Monte yard who you were trained to
be a medic he was a medic he'd been he'd
been a medic and and uh the main thing
cooch did was he watched my back
all the time you're on the ground in
Laos yeah yeah
absolutely and he watched my back on the
previous operation I was on so Iota you
know
but he also carried the medical supplies
he also helped with the wounded you know
it wasn't just me helping with the
wounded right
of course when we would I would pull in
some people from the line to help carry
the wounded and then change them out
periodically because you
I mean
if you've got some guy strapped to a
bamboo pool with the repelling ropes and
a poncho
and they look like one you know like
have you ever seen those pictures in the
distance where you see some guy carrying
two guys carrying a tiger yeah that's
basically what it looked like in
if you ever tried you're carrying dead
weight no mountain yard
probably most of them weighed probably
what somewhere between 150 pounds
but that's dead weight and if you're
trying to go through that jungle in Laos
I'm going to tell you
um I'm not so sure you could drive
through there with a bulldozer
well it also
um
within the next day you had at least two
people that were two of the distance
troops that were killed or died from the
wounds and that you tried to carry them
for another day then they finally had to
make a very difficult decision yeah all
right well there's we left we had three
killed and I'm the one
who made the decision who gave the order
to lead them yeah
and I will tell you
yeah there isn't a day go by for the
last 50 years
that
I know everybody's told me consciously I
know but there's something in the back
of my head that what I did that day were
actually two different days
yeah what's wrong because we left them
they were dead I don't know if they were
Buddhists I don't know if they're
Catholic because Mountain yards were
either Catholic or Buddhists right so
they didn't come home to their their
families they didn't get their
ritual or religious I should say burial
uh their bones are probably scattered to
the the Four Winds
um
they'll never probably be found
they they don't have a final resting
place
and I don't know their names
I
I I you know know very little about them
except that I'm the one who
that will not gave the order that
said
they're just not coming home right and
you had to do that in order to keep
those alive to be able to move more
proficiently when that jungle Triple
Canopy on top well we were struggling to
carry the wounded right
have you you know you can't you can't
carry a we didn't have litters so we
improvised with the pulp bamboo sure and
um when you're carrying a
basically resting
75 pounds on one shoulder
plus your rucksack and your weapon and
everything else and if you ever got to
walk through that part of the world
even if you were stripped down with
nothing it's extremely difficult to move
through that type of terrain yeah and
it's that difficulty was Captain
McCarley at that time decided
specifically that they would move at
night and they and that meant they had
air cover and so they had so after that
round went off everybody you patch
people up to the point people are on
stretchers and once you said everybody's
up and running then they moved at night
the mountain yard in tenant was the
worst he he was split from his hip wow
all right down to his femur to his knee
on on the I mean I'm trying to think the
right leg Yeah and uh
the thing that saved his life was
fortunately for him
considering that really devastating
woman that it did not
cut into the femorial artery oh yeah but
he still lost a lot of blood sure but
um
and one of the things that they talk
about
people think I did it deliberately but I
didn't it was Mother Nature uh flies got
into the wound
and as a result
all the badly wounded all had uh maggots
uh in their wounds I mean a lot so we
had maggots coming to the aid of a Green
Beret medic to help those wounded right
because they were eating the dead flesh
which meant they didn't get infection
yes and who would have thought of that I
not me and uh I mean in fact when we got
the one guy back to uh the 74th aback
the surgeon opened up the bandages and
looked down and said let me just put the
bandages back says they're doing a
better job than I could no kidding and
uh well because they do they get in
there and eat all the dead flesh sure
fortunately they weren't like a Bowflex
magnet that eats everything right but
these maggots were just eating the dead
flesh and they relatively kept the wound
clean yeah my biggest problem with them
though was
um I couldn't
I couldn't change the bandages after I
bandaged them and the reason for it is
every time you you know in that type of
environment you start pulling bandages
off you start disturbing stuff yeah so
uh when I interacting the healing
process going on well my no what I was
concerned about was
uh starting bleeding again once I got
the bleeding start right so
what I did was I just kept
as the advantages got soaked in blood I
just kept uh
um
put more bandages on it and then on
night or when I could I got an iv in
them to keep them hydrated right uh and
then uh fortunately they didn't have it
um you know gut wounds that we could
feed them water
to keep as much fluids demo as possible
and that was the other concern I had
with my really badly wounded was that
uh dehydration you know
blood loss plus you're sweating like
yeah in the jungle yeah and they're
moving and you could lose some water I
mean you know through sweat so that was
our my biggest concern was keeping them
hydrated and making sure they didn't
start to bleed again and uh I kept them
I gave them enough just enough morphine
not to kill the pain but to
because I gotta believe bouncing around
like we were bouncing them it had to
hurt I mean yeah I mean they had to be
absolutely miserable I can't imagine so
like by the end of that first night and
into the morning of the second
day on the ground by that time nine of
the 16 Green Berets have been wounded
and at that point you and [ __ ] were
working how do you say coach
thank you you and cooch have worked
tirelessly on the wounds all night as
they moved through the jungle in the
dark but I just wanted to have a a quick
moment because you knew and I talked
earlier off camera it was one of those
little moments in time the first day
when you have been on the ground for
maybe an hour they came to a a cachet an
enemy cache Supply site and it turned
out to be some kind of a weigh station
for the North Vietnamese Army and while
they were in it what was it what was the
exact configuration of that uh we think
it was probably like a core Logistics
Center it had class A phones by that if
you don't know what a Class A phone is
it's like the thing that's in your home
yes it had some of the uh areas had some
wooden sidewalks
uh they were structures that weren't I
mean by our standards I guess they would
be considered temporary but they were
more
the structures were more secure or
sturdy than a simple you know
build it in the half an hour and so here
you have one of these moments in time
where
one of those phones right yes and
Captain G McCoy got it's in the book but
I never knew it was Gene and so what
happened when the phone rang well I'm
standing there because I heard him say
this and he said uh the phone rang he
picks it up he says captain Eugene
mccarley's Special Forces Group how may
I help you
and I and I'm going oh
can I say I can't you can you can yes
this is Jocko's world yeah I said a
little [ __ ] for me I mean this
okay why don't we just carry them you
know break out the colors guys you
unsheet the colors you know it's like
I mean but you know you know we go in
sterile and all that but it's like
it's like making a movie and not
identifying it at the uh the actor who's
playing a particular character and you
know that's Matt Damon and or uh Cary
Grant or John Wayne you know who it is
because that was part of the secret war
was our government had entered an
agreement somewhere a treaty or
something with the North Vietnamese they
said we will not have combat troops and
layoffs we said we won't we pulled them
all out and the NBA being The Honorable
Congress they are added more and so
there's always that secret War we were
there they didn't acknowledge that they
were there but we knew they were and I
was part of the uh the war so here's the
phone he answers it and I wanted to
spell something else that has come up is
there were no
surveillance in that area
there were you you there was no evidence
of farming
there was no evidence of any kind of uh
civil action at all in that area that's
why we'll talk about that later on as to
why that issue became a central leader
like 30 years later yeah I mean it was
you're it was it it was a combat area
unbeknownst to the most of the world but
it was it was it was not a safe place to
be and I can tell you farmers are not
going to be
uh rape trying to raise rice or pigs or
chickens or whatever if you're dropping
bombs and mortars and whatever else on
them
yeah I mean it's yeah
because you know you're
it isn't worth the effort so what you're
going to do is you you move off
to what you consider a safer area or
and so I can tell you as a matter of
fact you I saw an absolutely zero
evidence of civilization other than that
Logistics Center that the North
Vietnamese had built
and uh that area also had a
must have been a way station for troops
heading south too because there was
there was actually a post office there
no kidding with uh we actually got mail
first class mail I mean we're talking
it's your letters home with a stamp and
this is the first command post that you
hit you take the intelligence and then
when you all moved out the debt and the
engineers set everything up to blow it
up destroy it I remember nine tons of
rice and weapons yeah and then also we
uh definitely identified the area
and I understand that the Air Force came
in and just blew the
Daylights they follow your smoke from
where yeah they came in and I unders I
don't know what they hit it with but
they they worked that area and I
understand there was
I don't know what the length of time but
there were secondary and tertiary
explosions going on so oh yeah for
several hours yes which is that shows
you how deep the supply routes were and
the lines were there that that was a
major impact on day one and so I'm sure
we irritated somebody and that's what I
think they started pulling troops off of
uh the CIA operation was the Northwest
of Shavano and we were southish Avenue
right and I think they started pulling
troops off of that operation because
now this is my gross supposition indeed
I mean I can't prove this Sergeant Rose
at the time well actually it's an old
man Rose thinking back we we probably
had created a thought process in the NBA
that this may have been a major U.S
incursion in the Laos
which it wasn't but
with uh when if you you know if a small
group creates a lot of Havoc oh yeah and
you're and you're in that environment
you probably you don't have the
satellites you don't have all the you
know back in those days no satellites
yeah you you you didn't have all the
electronic the night vision and all that
stuff nothing like that and uh or at
least they didn't so they're they're
probably wondering
who's in there doing what and then with
McCarley moving this constantly because
historically we'd go in and we'd create
a static position to draw them right so
for a historic perspective they had done
three slam operations where hatch of
force would go in set up on the Ho Chi
Minh trail and stay permanent and then
after a while the NBA would hammer
Gene's response we will move day and
night so they won't know exactly where
you were so they couldn't muster large
forces at least the first couple of days
are on the ground but they kept coming
at you yeah exactly but they
they couldn't concentrate their troops
because they weren't sure where we were
because uh artists our great Commander
Gene McCartney I mean later Colonel
McCarthy Lieutenant Colonel McConnell he
uh the guy as far as I'm concerned
since April of 1775 he's probably within
the top five or ten individuals that
have ever commanded an infantry company
in the United States military I second
that notion he was just heroic I mean
and when you consider
that
well you know if you consider the amount
of wounded we had but we only had three
Kias
uh
and considering the damage we did and
our mission was a success
from what I learned 30 some years later
um
he he just was astoundingly great
Commander absolutely no question and I
want to get back to some more one more
personal point of lessons learned by you
when you're on the ground and again
they're just going back to the book
um at one point doing an attack on Bee
Company by an NVA force of more than 40
enemy Soldiers the two most seriously
wounded men that Rose was treating had
both of their IV fluid bags shattered
and destroyed during a hail of enemy
gunfire and quoting you in the book I
learned a lesson right there and then
said Rose
we kept the IVs flowing from load
positions allowing gravity to work but
not high enough for any meat gunfire to
destroy them
my God what a what a lesson to learn you
know I who would have thought
you know you you know you go through all
your medical training yeah and if this
is the best if anybody's either been in
a hospital or either as a patient or a
visitor and has seen somebody with an IB
bag they always got it on a hanging on a
hook like a foot or two feet above their
head at least right at least because you
and the reason you want gravity to do it
is because you don't want to be forcing
fluids
creating pressure in your system
unnecessarily right and uh so I will
well there were a couple times on the IB
I sat on one or two to force
I sorry but I had to force the flu is
full yeah I can see my instructors at
Special Forces medical training just
going to eight when they saw what I was
doing and then the other thing I was
doing that was a big No-No was I knew I
had a limited amount of morphine
and we had the morphine threats right it
looked like a a small tube of toothpaste
with a long needle yeah or like today's
small super glue they come as little
shoes with a little yeah and a very
sharp needle very thin yes well I would
probably use
one thread on three people
and no alcohol swabs oh because those
are gone within the first day trust me
yes I mean at that point in time you're
not concerned with um
we'll deal with infection later coming
to deal
you know you hope you hope somebody
I I mean this is all hindsight now yeah
you know I'm thinking well maybe uh
maybe a subconscious I was hoping that
none of these guys had it's some kind of
catastrophic disease you know you know
because if they did all of them at it
but you you can't you can't we couldn't
get resupplied my God every time they
try to get a helicopter and they they
were shooting them down well another big
factor too was you wanted to get a meta
back in to take out the wounded but you
couldn't because even on day two the
Tactical Air was even a hampered by bad
weather so you couldn't get tack Aaron
for a while as well as when you're
moving on the ground and we couldn't get
the medevax out that was one more uh
sidebar you all had to deal with so you
had to continue to move continue to take
care of your wounded and the Nevers grew
amongst the wounded because of the
ongoing combat as they move even at
night
crew and I and I can tell you to be the
the Moxie of
guys that were with us both the
Americans and the
a lot of them had wounds
or injuries that at that point
um that if you were here in Huntsville
you'd be calling 9-1-1 or at least
taking on the emergency room right but
you know you look at it okay you're not
bleeding too bad you're not going to die
today just if it you know you're not
going to die today you know if it if you
could get the fragment out or whatever
it was or put you put a bandage on it
pat them on the butt give them their
rifle and put them back on the line
because we you know you
we were it was getting desperate as each
day come yeah in the in the in the
fourth day had really become Beyond
desperate well even let's get back to
the third day for a second because even
there they finally did try to get the
meta back in
and that on on uh
that with the ch-53 again the Marine
Corps ch-53 Delta came in to pick up the
wounded the pilot was Bill beardall and
they came in uh our Green Beret medic
doc pageant John doc pageant was on that
helicopter with Sergeant John Brown and
as the helicopter began to descend into
the LZ you and a couple other people had
the most seriously wounded that
Lieutenant was with you and a helicopter
you were just beginning to reach up to
hand the lieutenant over the doc pageant
when uh the Tail Road struck a tree and
as you were lifting the patient up
towards Doc and the chapter suddenly
lifted up Suddenly it was lifting up
like it took off
well and you're and you're on the
receiving end of that
after discussing that years later
decades later yeah
I remember a I guess it was a pop not a
palm tree but either well some kind of
tree or bamboo you know probably about
maybe six inches in diameter at the base
yeah and it was in this middle of what
looked like an old bomb crater I think
it because we didn't clear it and we
were in a clearing of sorts yeah just
try and find a clear spot to get the
chopper and lift up the wounded and I
the guys had chopped most of that down
with uh with with knives
we didn't have access so they were
trying to get that thing as low as
possible
and I think what hap we think what
happened is
that particular helicopter we think took
a hit of some sort and what happened was
when it it wasn't uh
a critical hit per se right
but what happened when it when it got
hit the rotors swung in and hit that
tree that we didn't get quite get slow
enough yeah because the helicopters I
remember we were in like a bowl like a
fair as I as I think about it sure yeah
and I he couldn't really set down flat
so the front end was going to be
somewhat up
up against the the side of a bomb crater
or whatever created that yeah bull-like
effect and now this is what we think
and um
so when it got hit with something and
I'm not sure what it was I think the
pilot for a minute jerked and the thing
slightly hit and the rear rotor hit that
that the berry top of the
uh yeah tree and once you lose a rear
rotor
or damage it or bend it my understanding
is very difficult to control a
helicopter so he had no other choice but
to lift off and get out of there right
because the last thing we needed was a
downed helicopter on top of everything
else and then we'd have God knows how
many more injured with a crashed
helicopter well then doc pageant also
said that another round had gone through
and it hit uh the one of the fuel
containers and so they had fuel or some
kind of liquid flowing inside of the
helicopter on top of everything else
so that helicopter did get out of there
but you could not get the wounded out no
so you had to go back to the Jungle that
helicopter went out it did a emergency
landing we kept pushing like this yeah
well hoping nobody can see me on a radio
but pushing up like you're doing above
our heads right and they were trying to
pull them in but
um that that particular helicopter was
really not designed as a Medevac per se
so you either at the side door you had
the tailgate yeah and we were trying to
get them up through the tailgate
no that's true that's what doc said too
and he doesn't don't forget another
sidebar to that was as they came in this
is according to the door gunner uh Larry
grow
and
he had his M60
and a 51 caliber anti-aircraft machine
got opened up on the helicopter and he
was able to he said quote it was only 25
yards from it and he opened up with it
with his M60
and held it down full automatic until
the 51 was silenced that was also going
on in addition to all the other activity
on at that moment in time yeah this was
a this was a great idea that from the
very beginning started going bad
and I I do the right thing and I uh and
I gave great credit to that that crew
because they got that helicopter because
the last thing like I said is that that
had pancake again with all if the and I
did not know about the fuel until you
just told me about that yeah now that I
remember reading the book yeah now like
okay
but anyway you know I'm getting old guys
and things don't you're not 29 anymore
not 22 anymore but if you
you have to give great credit for them
because they had enough sense to know
and then this is what I'm thinking we
don't we did not need that to hit that
that where we were because we would have
taken characters on the ground plus the
casualties in me and then we would have
struggled with trying to get them out of
the helicopter
plus if he hadn't silenced that weapon
which
uh we would have had the um the
additional problem of that weapon going
at us right and uh you know our handfuls
are in and you never know on a
helicopter crash you know people
everybody could get killed or everyone
can walk away from it or something in
between
but my biggest fear now that I
think about the fuel issue is on that
thing if it had exploded in that bowl it
would have taken I mean that mission
would have been over then right there so
him the pilot especially the crew got
that up and got it away and I don't know
how far they got before they crashed but
I forget these activity got far enough
away so that the enemy wasn't firing
when they did an emergency landing and
then another copter came in lifted him
out on the ladder and a doc led the
people up the ladder and then the
helicopter took off there's that iconic
photo of The Siege 53 Delta flying East
with Doc and the other uh members of
that helicopter crew that went down on
it at Ian Brown world
yeah and I mean it's just amazing it's
just amazing and and the attempt that
doc pageant and Doc Brown
coming in to make that attempt like that
was uh
probably if you if they had sat down and
really thought about it yeah
the thought probably went across their
mind this is probably not a good idea
I mean
because you guys have been drawn intense
Fire by that time this is day three now
yeah by then they pretty much
they probably probably didn't know they
didn't really know exactly where you
were until day four but by then they
pretty much knew the general area we
were in right
and uh so the mission has been planned
to go for what five or seven days
but on day four in the morning at the
very first briefing in tonight which is
before anybody on the ground knew this
the people that were briefing was that
the weather
was getting closing in and would make it
impossible for attack air to support
operation tl1 also the NBA were closing
in and so in that morning everything
changed
um but also you also had another
intelligence coup during that morning
they hit another command post get the
intelligence there's fire fights along
the way just an amazing day and you
meanwhile are attending to the
increasing number of wounded you a cooch
are moving on taking care of your men
and this is day four and uh
you know I I want to say something else
please
if we had come across it I know this for
a fact if we'd have come across in the
ability
one we would not have heard of right and
two with being as conservative as I
would have been I would have if they
were still alive I I would have tried to
do something
keep them going long enough for their
own people to pick them up right
and uh because
I guess my attitude was that once
they're down yeah they're down and you
know and
they
they probably wanted to be home just as
much as the rest of us wanted to be
that's the difference between our army
Green Berets and the Communists
because we have many situations we have
wounded personnel and they would just
come along and summarily execute well on
my first mission uh
the
in June of that year I the most severely
wounded person I had was an MBA is that
right yeah
I did everything to
save his life
I left him with
he passed away
uh I had put an IV in them
I had give it a morphine and I'd had the
cigarette in the collar in the collar
and I wrote a note in English told them
what I'd done and left it with them
you do that in the call so anybody picks
him up knows that they've had morphine
yeah that would impact the triaging and
their treatment yeah exactly and you
don't want to give them a morphine than
necessary right I mean you don't want to
make an attic out of them but you can
kill people with overdose you know with
morphine well it's a drug it's it's
you know
well how many times you heard about
people that were gut shot and they're on
morphine they're gone oh look at my look
at my guts hanging out we've heard
stories like that it's just amazing
people never think about that aspect of
being wounded well my philosophy in
combat as far as in the field I never
would give anybody a morphine to kill
the pain
I would give them enough morphine
so they could tolerate it yeah and the
reef there's a reason for that if
they're
if they're if they can tolerate the pain
then you can talk to
you can reassure them
uh and you can also if they're out
because you gave them so much morphine
then any other sign or symptom that may
pop up you it's probably not going to
make an appearance
that you'd like to to do something else
or or whatever you could within your
poor abilities
so and and the other thing too is
if you get a Meda backed out of the
field back to say a 70 a like the 74th
and back that's right
Q play Q uh play Q yeah uh then
they could if the guy's conscious enough
to be even though he's a little groggy
you can talk to them they can talk to
them
you know yeah and then first and then
they and then they can get more
reassurance especially because if you're
giving somebody morphine in the field
they're probably got a pretty serious
injury
and you know in the serious injuries in
combat you know the first stock that
most that's the biggest one of the
biggest things you have with is shock if
they go into shock you can lose it right
and and you want to keep them out of
shock
and they can go into shock even if
they're if they're doped up on morphine
so you don't want them so doped up that
you can't monitor shock at least that's
my fault that was my philosophy sure and
I had I had learned that from an old
Special Forces May when I was going
through training well is that right it
it may be anecdotal right it may be
somebody could maybe challenge me on
that technically
okay but that was my philosophy and
that's the way I was going to operate
that's the way it worked in the field
you brought people back alive and it
worked on that operation I never gave
nobody was so
um
because when we were carrying those two
guys that were really couldn't walk at
all sure you could hear them when we'd
bump him or something oh yeah so
I knew that this sounds terrible
it's as long as I heard them open or
ouch
or
I knew they were alive they're still
with us they were still with us and
you know I mean that's that's somewhat
of a
I mean I learned that not from school
but I learned it from other Medics older
medics
that I had been around for a while you
know he sharpens and he ate that had you
know because even though I would
graduate from Special Forces had been in
Thailand I still worked with Medics that
were had more experience than I do
confident experience combat experience
and you listen to them because the last
thing you want to do is you want to
further injure somebody that's already
in a tight spot hurt for certain yeah
and especially in a situation where it's
not like you can call 9-1-1 and an
ambulance is going to show them
because you don't know in our in my
situation after the first date
I don't we never really attempted to
Medevac the woman because the that
second day we're trying to evacuate them
proved to be a disaster
so we we didn't want to put another
helicopter in danger we didn't want to
put more crew in danger in right and
plus the fact to Medevac that many
wounded at that point
uh
you've got to have more assets
than in the air
and they're having trouble with the
weather even that day yeah so it's it's
just it wasn't just I mean you got to
think Beyond
you sometimes you have to make hard
decisions
fortunately for me I'm not the one
making this I never made the decision
about no more medevax that was not my
purview that was but it but in hindsight
it was the right decision it was
it was it was Common Sense sure I mean I
don't I don't want to see brown or
pageant hurt or that crew hurt right
like they almost did anyway
yeah so this so and that rescue was on
the third day and so now day four so the
every the teams inserted September 11th
we go through the 12th the 13th day and
night combat moving always combat during
the night they even use tactical error
night we had uh specters yeah uh sting
and then uh other gunships that provided
coverage so that Captain McCarley or his
combo man could direct airstrikes on the
enemy as they're attacking your
positions at night while you're on the
Move meanwhile you and Coach are taking
care of the Wounded As you move and well
I can tell you this much yeah anything
you tell me about mccarley's
I don't know firsthand because I I saw
him at Carly
uh and here here's the great thing about
how great a commander he was
if I can plead that aside oh yeah even
with all the stuff he was doing he
wasn't eating he wasn't sleeping and he
was drinking whatever that water we
could fetch out of them places we were
different canteens
um
he would he would come by
not all the time but periodically a
couple three times maybe I don't know I
can't remember it could be one it could
have been five I don't know but the fact
of the matter is he came by he's
fighting this whole thing he comes to
you he comes to me and he has he asks me
how I'm doing he wasn't asking how
Sergeant Rose the medic was doing he was
asking how Mike Rose was doing yeah
the man on the ground and I know talking
to other people that he was doing that
with the other guys yeah and that
included the mountain yards too
yeah you know you couldn't maybe you
couldn't talk to him but you could he
could walk by and you know Pat him on
the shoulder or he had a couple of words
and montenorities yeah
and uh and the same thing with Morris
Adair
um
the first sergeant I it would be remiss
and not mentioning him in the same
attitude he he was walking around
doing his first sergeant stuff you know
like making sure
distribution of ammo or whatever but he
would come by and he would chit chat
with you like we were in Central Park
yeah I mean he didn't stop me from doing
what I was doing but he would just chit
chat and I know what he was doing
he was just there
he knew I knew he had my back indeed
you know
absolutely and they all knew all the men
that talk to later also they knew what
you were doing which was patching them
up as well as the indigenous troops who
by that time we had over 50 casualties
that you and Coach are looking after
maintaining helping as well as moving at
the same time
oh I can tell you the things I we were
cooch and I were doing were probably
violating every
sanitary medical procedure that I'd ever
been taught and trained
but but at that point in time you know
it's like
it's you you and and then plus by day
four we were we were out of stuff right
if
I thank God that nobody really got
really badly hurt on the fourth day yeah
because I didn't have any morphine left
I mean because one of the things that I
did was all the Americans
everybody's left front pocket belonged
to me right because I made sure they had
extra morphine in there a bandage in
there and I made everyone in the
rucksare carry the big belly bands sure
yeah and everybody carry an IV bottle
and and that helps sustain you through
those four days off the ground I would
go and pull that stuff from them or
cooch would go and get it
you know sure and because I couldn't
carry all that stuff coops couldn't
carry all this stuff and the guys didn't
have any problems with carrying that
stuff right
if they went down they knew they would
need it that would be needed
yeah so let us turn to day four because
um and it's funny because again the
troops on the ground Captain McCarley
and the men his his command element
didn't have a accurate weather picture
yet but they started in the morning and
then they hit another command
headquarters
they go in seize more documents there's
combat there and
um trying to think and in addition to
intelligence documents papers code books
Transportation logs records North
Vietnamese currency and photographs
including a photograph of Ho Chi Minh
who had been the head of the Communists
in North Vietnam who died in 1968. but
again they got this another Intel coup
the guys had to pack this stuff and
carry it in addition to everything else
while engaged in the enemy on this
occasion they again use the uh as they
wired the area the weapons and the cache
site with the again rights weapons enemy
supplies
ignited as they pulled out continuing to
move and when it explodes then the Air
Force came back using that as a marker
to to completely destroy all the enemy
supplies the cachet which were
significant numbers you know it really
amazes me is
um
dried rice
you don't think about it but it'll burn
pretty good pretty if you get it if you
get it ignite it like throw it you know
if you have a cash of rice you throw a
thermic and eat in there
or put a little gasoline in there yeah
yep
it'll I don't know if it'll completely
destroy it but it'll make it unusable
you can't eat it right that's then
that's all you're interested little map
can go a long way with rice yep so um
but you know well you know if you if you
on rice if you're cooking rice at the
house and you forget about it on the
stove and the water all boils out it'll
start to burn
right
you can imagine what you know really
thoroughly dried rice that's never been
in water do it's it's like any other
dried uh piece of vegetation
will burn
I mean that's uh that's a big uh
challenge with uh
wheat silos in the United States is
if you're not careful with that you can
they can be launched in outer space
that's right that's a horrific because
explosions explosives because of that
yeah so
you never know
well rice flour you know or or wheat
flour is very dangerous
because it'll it burns so quick it's
almost like an explosion right and so
getting back to day four uh finally Gene
was told about the weather and the areas
that started to come out Joe Driscoll
was there with Scarface and they came
out the gifts of support and then later
we had Tom stump who was a pilot with an
A1 Sky reader and Joe and they thought
there was over a thousand NVA past that
Lal
troops who are moving towards Company B
in the morning now Gene didn't know the
numbers were that big but they knew the
enemy was coming they told them and Joe
Drisco
looked at he said during that final
briefing was very clear today was Do or
Die
the big thing was the Stark seriousness
of the moment everyone knew they had
suffered heavy casualties as you knew
firsthand and now the weather was
closing in on it
today was Sky reader pilot Tom stuff had
added the weather was dog [ __ ] when we
took off I wasn't optimistic about
getting them out of there
and that's what you all are up against
on the ground well day four I was later
told that I don't know who Tom was
talking to over the radio eventually
well the reflect said to somebody and I
don't know who he was talking to over
the radio yeah if we don't get him out
now we're not getting them out
and he played a key role in protecting
you all because at one point the NBA
were coming up with some wave attacks
Covey had left but Gene McCarley was
able to talk to Tom Stone who found a
way through the clouds and then made
several Gun Runners that broke the back
well told like I I said this morning at
the purpose that they they the money
Pilots were told not to fly under 500
feet and I don't know if that was a
standard order or whatever
but later on I found out it was Tom
stump but he made a pass over us
and uh the way the 50 calibers operate
this is why for years I thought Tom was
taking hits and what it was was the
rounds come up with no prob pushes the
rounds back up the expense cartridges
yes indeed so what I was seeing was the
shadowing of those 50 caliber rounds
along its fuselage but when he turned
and looked down I couldn't read it but I
could see that there was lettering on
his helmet that's how low he was really
and what scared the crap out of me
because at first I thought he was
strafing us but it wasn't you know what
it was it was the expense 50 caliber uh
and I mean those those things were going
everywhere when they were hitting the
ground and I and I suspect they were
going how fast are they going I don't
know but they're what two three inches
like a small tube of crust yeah and uh
it's funny now but at the time it wasn't
that stuff was going everywhere I mean
except it never hit a single person got
hit with one of those extent round and I
don't I don't you know what
to me that's why I believe firmly you
know I am a somewhat of a religious man
I'm Catholic I go attend church and
whatever on regular
but when I think back about it there's
little incidents like that that say to
me
there are Guardian Angels there are
there is a divine intervention
intervention and saying yeah these
nobody's going to get hurt on this
and somehow he the good Lord pushed
those
spent
rounds indeed
in such a way as nobody got hit because
if you've got it when they're hot and
two they they're probably traveling a
couple hundred miles an hour oh yeah
either particularly on a gun run yeah
because they're coming down
those birds as War Birds those
magnificents highest as low as he was I
should say uh
well one of our targets we had a gun run
in the [ __ ] where the A1 Sky A1
skygrader pilot after his gun run
he put the bird on its side to look at
me I could see him and I could tell you
he was smoking a Philly charu
and I saluted him so he went past that's
how close they were yeah it's just like
what you're saying
yeah those same one eight Pilots man
they're the crazy bunch of guys and it
could keep flying through all that
anti-aircraft stuff in the Sam's and
everything it's just
and I think they're one of the keys that
are success was the fact that a lot of
them flew where particularly when it
came to a gun run or a Napalm Strike
they flew not from 5 000 feet but they
were closer much closer to the deck
maybe violating that 500 foot rule too
but we aim to try to get a future uh
spad pile of an A1 pylon here someday
we're working on that right now for
somewhere yeah I've always wondered if
that low out to those those
some of the anti-aircraft
weapons that the NBA had
were really not designed to go after a
and in that jungle you're you know
you're you're
up your quadrant in elevation right was
limited from the canopy well that would
you know where they would put those
things I would suspect but I don't
really think that they had
um were really designed or or operating
to go after aircraft that low
and I understand uh talking to other
people one of the reasons we didn't lose
more Huey's
was because
a lot of the NBA didn't lead
the Huey far enough you know they would
aim at that and by the time of the
rounds got there the Huey was already
passed
so a lot of you know it's like our field
artillery you know it's you you don't
aim at the Target you know the Earth
moves and they are around spins to the
left and and the round and the target
collide
so
oh yeah
because of the distance involved indeed
so on this day uh getting back to day
four
um the enemy kept coming by now they're
rolling into the team like you said
they've located where you are
dig just you all your team has destroyed
the enemy headquarters cachet site
and you're moving forward and at some
point the enemy's coming so heavily
between the gun runs that in order to
break the attack they came in with cs
gas which is tear gas yeah it's the same
thing that does in fact my understanding
CS was originally developed by the
for use by uh
for police in rat control
now it's not a lethal gas no as long as
you're not in a like a room or something
they fill it up with but you know you
know CO2 can do the same thing but uh
but I will tell you something
CS is the only cure I know for a common
cold or sinus infection yeah that'll
work within minutes because I tell you
what you get that stuff up in your
sinuses
if you have a bacterial infection or
viral infection
those little guys are climbing over each
other to get out of your nose I'm
telling you because that's the you your
eyes you can't get your eyes open you're
you're you feel like you can't breathe
yeah uh you're you're your nose begins
to run at a massive amount it's very
unpleasant oh god well you know like
Gene McCauley said the one of the
reasons why he called in to see us was
because they were desperate the hordes
the NBA hordes were coming to the team
and they hit it with C with the Cs and
that made it possible for the
helicopters eventually the land and Gene
had that quote so we had a lot of our
guys crying and choking on that CS but
it also brought them critical time
and so then Scarface the cobras made gun
runs and The Siege 53 the first one came
in for the first troop pickup they pick
up one third of the force yeah they
leave we got the wounded half on the
first one yeah plus the yard I will say
Mountain yard I don't know if you want
to use the word panic or they they tend
to get out of there they're ready to go
home well you know the thing is with it
as many that got on that first
helicopter when you think in hindsight
I'm surprised it got off the ground
no kidding I mean it was overloaded yeah
now the second one wasn't as overloaded
but it uh
and the second one as it comes in
there's increase has more gunfire on it
enemy gunfire than the first one
and after they the second one picked up
then only left about 35 of us on the
ground right
35 out if there's no
130 but you went in 133. so the first
two helicopters picked up pretty close
to 100 people wow and I I'm really
surprised that they in that you know the
helicopters are not known for flying
very well in hot weather
they love the article from
Ohio but indeed uh
but and then we were taking a lot of
fire and then of course we're on the
line
and we were started taking more wounded
excuse me that's okay yeah so so now
we're down to the third helicopter again
Scarface the Cobras did the gun runs
and then the third seeds 53 Delta Marine
Corps helicopter comes in to pick up
more troops
and um so you all are getting on the
helicopter and uh penske's flying yes
yes indeed and so so on a Final Approach
and they knew that they were good that
this was a last chance to get you all
out
and
um Sergeant Mike Hagan was one of the
team members said
I can tell you that big bird was a
welcome sight to us
we were all beat we were all wounded and
we were all ready to go home believe me
and Mike was on that you Mike and a few
others were the last Gene were the last
ones to get on that helicopter I got um
I got on in Morris Adair got on
and Gene McCarley
was the last member
of the company
That Special Forces Group command
control Central right he was the last
man to step off that field and even
before he stepped off a few minutes
earlier when he was standing there with
a radio operator
Monty or standing investment was killed
stand it right next to him and then uh
like Gene said it was one of those
moments in time the mountain yard was
shot in the head there was blood all
over the place now I I'm not
I I know I don't I I pick we did I know
um
I can't remember if he was killed
because I remember we were
we didn't leave anybody on the ground
I'm not sure if he was killed or he was
just
at first one of them there were there
were there was one I know for sure
because I gave my weapon to Pete Landon
and I went forward and grabbed a guy
that went down he'd gotten hit in the
head and I'm dragging him back to the
ship I got him on board
and I remember yeah I think that's the
one and he was I mean
that was even his fellow Mountain yard
told Gene him dead
they all thought he was dead but but
you're the medic but he was he I
remember his whole head was just in case
well you know how baffle you your head
bleeds headphone can't imagine a a
around bouncing off from the front of
your all the way back
and
it looked like the thing that I don't
know what he got hit with but uh
the track was about it as I remember it
looked like it was about half an inch
air skin and hair and everything was
missing oh wow
and he was just his whole head was
encased in blood
so we threw him on a helicopter I but he
didn't die that and I think and you know
when you when you talk about that uh I
read that and I'm thinking uh no because
that's one point I asked you about the
third the third one was killed when we
went down
uh after the extraction right and he
somehow got crushed with the helicopter
so there was a third one left at the
Christ site the two we left on the first
second day right and that fourth one
that was so badly hurt which was the
last guy yeah
he he made it back he was alive I don't
know how that's amazing I don't know how
well he did made it how well he was
afterwards but you got him back he was
still breathing when you got it back
yeah he was still breathing when we got
back to uh doctor yeah
um
and then
there was the marine and he yeah
we just set the scene for a second
through Tom stump because Tom again is
in the A1 looking down he was it was a
wild scene down there as we provide a
close cover to the team on the ground
Air Force F4 has attacked anti-aircraft
guns that the NBA had moved into the
area they the NBA really wanted them
they were masked to get them they wanted
to get back what the team had taken from
the base camp
cubby writers told us that the NBA 12.75
and Mike Mike and the 37 Mike Mike
anti-aircraft weapons were opening up on
us meanwhile Scarface Cobra gunships
reacted to enemy gunfire on their
position while Gene directed them
towards the enemy troops so things on
the ground even before you get on that
helicopter were just crazy yeah and and
if if you were to make a you if I made a
statement and you disagreed with it
right and you're on the ground I can't
argue with you yeah because
we hadn't slept for four days
we have I don't remember eating I really
don't remember eating probably did but I
don't remember yeah I remember drinking
a lot of nasty water
that's like I told somebody once that
you know you drop your canteen in that
water well you know the water was
probably clear until the first guy
walked through it right
you know the Clearwater and everybody
and then you throw a handful of iodine
in there which tastes like [ __ ] oh yeah
and then you're you're drinking that
stuff and you're spitting stuff out and
you hope what you're spitting out isn't
moving on its own you know indeed so uh
we were drinking water I know we were
drinking water because we were fairly
hydrated but because I was checking on
that kind of stuff
also and uh
but
but you were exhausted and and
people talk about the fog of War sure
yeah I remember I remember there's a
Hollywood effect that that I've seen in
movies before like in a battle scene and
I remember this one battle scene it was
a takes place between two a British ship
and a pirate ship right and they're
firing at each other
and
the sound goes dead and all you see is
the effects of stuff
slowing up and exploding but you don't
hear any sound
and
it's like a fog you're just kind of the
fog of War yeah and that's why I'm
saying it
am I wrong I could be are you wrong you
could be or but it's probably something
in the middle sure because you've had
combat scenes where two people are
fighting and looking the same way and
they talk completely different stories
that just happens and like can we just
turn to What gene was saying yeah at
that last moment because Gene said as we
were backing up the ramp up the
helicopter ramp they were coming towards
us they were coming at us hard
I'm guessing the Cs guests had them
confused because they were getting too
close to us as me Mike Mars stood but
none of them threw a grenade into the
chopper I never understood why they did
they were that close
and they kept coming even as we lifted
off the LZ while mowing down NVA
soldiers
they just can't imagine and you don't
want to hear something really silly yeah
I can remember that at that point there
were only three of us on the ground
right there was the captain Morris and
myself
I'm looking away from the helicopter
right
I don't remember seeing any NBA
is that right
I don't yeah and I I remember uh I
remember
I can't remember if it was a McCarley or
it was probably Morris because he was
closer to me because Carly was
behind Morris and then or and then I was
in front of Morris right so it probably
was Morris that kind of shoved me or
pushed me up the ramp and I remember and
Bernie Brown Bernie bright grabbed me by
the I remember him and sitting me down
at the top of the ramp yeah
and I can remember Morris and the
colonel coming up the ramp yeah
but if you were to ask me which one came
up first
I I can't tell you I just remembered two
figures coming at me sure I knew they
were well plus they're coming into the
darkness of the helicopter from the
outside light so I don't know which one
came out first
and then and I'm sitting there and then
it's kind of like
and I'm sure we're taking rounds okay
let me help you here because in the book
persky the pilot and others offset the
helicopter was getting hit with rounds
and as you said you sat down and as the
helicopter began to lift off marine
sergeant Stevens was bleeding profusely
from a gunshot wound in the neck
and you then treated him as the
helicopters taking off could you
explained it better to me today than we
did in the book The Round went through
his neck
and then at some point
here's another thing from the the Medics
that your medic perspective that I
really enjoyed of all the points was uh
you you were trying to treat him and you
could tell that he's see he was very
lucky I'm quoting you now life he was
very lucky that round had missed the
courted Arty and the trachea yet he was
going in the shot I rolled him over got
him on all fours
and I remember telling him listen you
lucky son of a [ __ ] if you're gonna die
you'd be dead by now
I didn't use the word lucky
[Laughter]
I I think I said
I think I said listen you stupid son of
a [ __ ] if you were going to die you'd
be dead by now I think I used the word
stupid but you know what yeah but it
worked but it worked he came out of
shock yes and he began to bounce back
and
and uh
and that's all I did I mean and I I
remember uh what do you do to to stand
up bleeding from I wouldn't worry about
that you know what I was worried about
no what
if he had hit anything I knew if he'd
hit anything vital right he no he he was
caught he would have been dead by the
time he hit the ground because you hit
those carotids oh yeah I mean you bleed
out probably what
10 seconds quit something like that
I was worried about his head bobbing
because if you're you can't it's muscled
church was and he probably couldn't hold
his head so and don't ask me what I
wrapped his neck in I won't because I
can't tell you I think it either had to
be shirt sleeves or kerchiefs or you
know that well the cold like rose then I
found something to wrap around the neck
to get the bleeding to stop
that's what you did something I did
something I don't remember what it was
but I stabilized his head so it wasn't
moving and then the next thing I know
I'm sitting on the on a beach well wait
wait because you're forgetting just a
little bit more of the drama here on day
four as you're repairing Sergeant
Steven's neck
the helicopters rising over a
Mountaintop and one of the engines one
of the two engines goes out now you may
not be aware of this because you're busy
with Sergeant Stevens and the troops
that they're looking at the mountains
you're flying over and then
um they were well aware of the danger
and of course uh the the pilot I guess
it would be lieutenant persky
he said that bridge line was sheer
granted and he was scared about crashing
into that Granite they finally get over
one more mountain top oh yeah now you
tell me yeah yeah I didn't even know
that yeah you know but I mean it's in
the book yeah I know oh indeed but I'm
going oh crap yeah and so the second
engine goes out and then you should have
never read the book that's right well I
put pictures in it yeah
and so the as they got over the second
Granite Ridge line it had flown over now
the big war bird was struggling there
are hydraulic fluids and blood
everywhere inside the helicopter
according to Rose and the tail was lower
than it should be we could tell
something was wrong really wrong
we just didn't know how wrong
and so the second engine goes out
and then uh there's that moment in time
where he's descending he's into auto
rotation auto rotation is when the
helicopter to wait and he and the air
moves the propeller enough so that they
don't crash but it's definitely going
down with the controlled descent to his
extent and
um
mayday mayday and he said don't need
people to come back and say Hey you can
see an LZ or you'd go here there was
complete radio silence so he looked for
an area as he's descending and it's an
area that he'd never trained in training
with a ch-53 Delta with loaded with
troops intelligence information bleeding
Marines and
they're all rotating in and so land so
finally it has a very harsh landing and
there's a problem
[Laughter]
the two answers are out you know the
inboard mechanic should have solved that
right yes it affects the bushy slacking
yeah because it must have been taking a
nap but let me that you know here's
another perspective on that scenario oh
please
um when I got up and and Bernie sat me
down right
we had
we were lifting up
and he was struggling because uh he lost
one engine going in and and uh and there
was hydraulic fluid stuffless
was obviously because there was water or
I probably thought it was water I don't
know what it was
all over the floor and that I remember
the tail going like this
and I could see green and then blue and
then green and I don't know which one of
us said this and Bernie in a bright
night to this day can't tell you one of
us said we're going to crash
and the other one said yeah I know and
we were arm and arm figuring
bend over and yes you know what goodbye
and that's when I got tapped on the
shoulder
now you gotta you can't believe this
there was a marine captain
no
darch fatigues
a spit shine boots no look like he was
getting ready to take a photo op for a
Marine Corps Recruiting poster indeed
and he said I got a wound it into that
so I got it and went back there yeah and
I remember that cap that's one thing
that stuck in my hand and it's like you
know we all look like [ __ ] yeah you're
sweaty bloody uh you know yes any any
no offense to officers and Colonels but
you know if any Colonel had seen any of
us we'd have been court-martialed for
our lack of military Recruitment and
dress right but I mean it was the funny
things to stick in your head I and I
remember him I can't remember his face
or his name is but I remember him and
what he was doing was he had a headset
on and he was controlling or talking to
the pilot about what was going on the
ground from what he could see from
tailgate yeah because when the he had
already you know normally when a
helicopter comes down
then they dropped the ramp
but when he was coming down
he had already fully dropped the ramp
really right
huh
because
I don't think there would have been time
to hit the ground and drop the ramp
because as soon as those and I and I got
to believe
I have to believe that the first two
pilots that came down
also it dropped the ramp and I don't
know if that's according to Hoyle or
what
but there was no
there was literally no time I think
because when you see those ramps come
down
yeah uh the ramp comes down like this
right
you got to stand there and wait
because I don't I don't think they
wanted us to wait they were trying to
get us out so they dropped
so he I think that Marine Captain was
controlling or talked or keeping he was
the eyes and the ears of the pilot
focusing back right looking at what's
going on well also any which probably
was waiting for us to get up and he'd
say Okay pull the ramp up but guess what
the ramp never came up no Hydraulics no
Hydraulics and you know Lieutenant
Colonel Air Force Lieutenant Colonel Mel
Swanson observed your warp that
helicopter descending into the canyon
and this was his impression
it was a kind of a depression he headed
towards the helicopter was trailing
smoke it was ugly real ugly I worried
that it might explode in midair or Worse
hit one of those Granite mountains in
the jungle from my seat in the old
trusty A1 Skyraider I couldn't see any z
l z or any area that was open large
enough for those Marines to land that
big bird without crashing and by now I
had heard they were Auto rotating with a
chopper full of troops it didn't look
good it impacted on a side angle in Leos
and it was appeared to be a sandy beach
with some water around it but yeah we're
seeing a creek or a river yeah okay I
don't know what yeah it wasn't a lake
when that helicopter hit was Sudden
Impact forceful impact so much so that
jeans teeth were crushed
14 teeth right down to the roots were
gone
well that's the count I found out later
yeah of course and uh
but by the way I should tell you that
Marine Corps and I were not on the
helicopter when it crashed
okay where we all bite we were already
on the ground
how'd that happen
Apparently one of the pilots said he saw
two bodies go up you know there's two uh
50 gallon gun ports right short on the
front yeah
if you see that picture of me with the
two beers and Thomas and and uh Spurgeon
on both sides right if you take a real
good look there's a
a scab right here
where what is it it's you can see it
when I okay okay when I crank my there's
a crease here yeah sure you still got it
yeah
well
we when that rolled the two of us went
this way and when it went this way
apparently we're at the right angle to
go out the door and we were told that
they don't know how many feet some I've
heard 50 feet I've heard 20 feet but the
two of us were thrown out of the
helicopter and hit the beach whoa
had not been saying you would have been
dead yeah but whatever
yeah whatever then again when I say
there's if people don't believe it if
you don't if you anybody who was on that
operation whether you're an air in the
ground
if you don't believe in God
you're a fool
and I sincerely believe that because
this shouldn't happen
especially the Marines survived
another 42 years
yes
so all I remember is sitting there like
with my hands back
now this is what I'm now at this point
in time I can just get little vignettes
of like Shadows sure like I'm sitting
there and this blob is coming at me
and
I don't know if it's stopped 10 feet 20
feet 5 feet a foot I have no clue right
because your vision's still off I'm off
yeah my bell has been wrong so I get up
and I turn and look at the helicopter
now how the hell McCarley got out of
that helicopter I don't know
I'm not sure how Morris has taken a bath
in the river right we'll get to that in
a second I walked up to McCarley and I
looked at him said we we got to get back
this is what McCartney's telling me I
told him I don't remember doing this
no kidding but McCarley tells me yeah
that I walked up to him
and he says I said we got to get back on
that helicopter there's guys on there
right so he's later he said yes he did
say that too sure
and I mean he he told me letters you
know when I think about it now really
not one of the brightest decisions I
made to follow you on that burning
helicopter Bernie helicopter at that
yeah so we start and the reason I know
that helicopter was Tipsy Turvy because
all the people are at the bottom and
there was equipment pilot
Bernie Bart was buried up to his waist
in a rucksacks and rifles right you know
stuck from the aircraft all the Intel
reports you brought back in photos yeah
yeah and the only thing sticking out of
that mess was his feet no
yeah and he's cooking like crazy I can
remember that so we start throwing stuff
now
planchet crawled out somehow right we I
don't he doesn't remember how he got out
I don't remember him I don't even know
he's there in the hope we know it wasn't
the door right it was a hole in the side
of the aircraft wow no kidding
it had to be yeah
because the way the helicopter was
sitting on the ground it was cockeyed
yeah big time so I'm throwing stuff out
and every time I throw stuff up I'm hit
him in the head
we passed we started passing anybody
that was in there out just
and as they got on the ground and kind
of shook well you know come over help
help yeah so we're pulling and then I
remember going forward and helping the
pilots out of the
out of the uh
remember the palace compartment yeah
yeah
well I remember going forward that far
and I remember being with the pilots
but I can't remember if I helped him out
or if
go ahead we got him going right
where they gotta excuse me or they got
out on their own
but one of them or both of them he used
their infantryman to try to create a
perimeter which a lot of good that would
have gone we figured we had about 20
rounds left between them all of us not
to mention rifles had been really
stirred up sure hand guards were missing
they were broken and everything else on
impact yeah
so the next thing I know is there's a
helicopter
now this is what I remember sure I'm on
helicopter I don't remember getting off
I don't remember getting the ground I
remember summoning saying everybody's
clear
or empty or right or something
indicating to me that there was nobody
left in we weren't going back in for any
equipment
um
then the next thing I know is a
helicopter backs
the
kind of backs into the beach
and everybody
we shuffle them onto another helicopter
came in the fourth one it should have
been ours yeah
and you know if that third one had gone
down on that LZ it would have been over
with oh yeah so no question so
we shuffled people in and we get the
ride back
to cartoon
I guess yeah I remember
looking at the helicopter landing then
the next thing I really clearly remember
is standing at our launch point there at
doctor
and then
to really finish off the day we started
taking
mortar and artillery fire
from that NDA right Mountain up there
where they they fart every day on Doctor
yeah yeah and I remember standing there
like an idiot
watching a cobra fully armed Cobra and
getting hit and blowing up well it's
like
and then welcome home yeah so and the
guys were jumping into this we had it's
I don't know how it happened I remember
the guys were in the bunker yeah we had
to help them out there were so many of
them in there they couldn't get up on
themselves well you know it's like yeah
you know 12 men squeezed into a six-man
box kind of deal and I remember
passing out kind of yeah
because they tell me I did
and the next thing I know I'm sure
almost shirtless
because I was so soaked in blood
I would thought I was bleeding so they
were checking me out
but I was
surprisingly I had a lot of things in me
but nothing really what I
was what I would consider
life-threatening or critical
and the next thing I know
the next thing I remember
is I'm on a helicopter with a mountain
yard
and marced air heading back to Contin I
don't remember that Huey I don't
remember getting on it Huey
and the first started Morris dare tells
me he said I looked right at him and he
said if this damn thing crashes I'm
walking back
you know yeah like what you all been
through and uh
I get
the rest of the afternoon is a complete
blur
I remember going and take a shower and I
this and the probably the reason I
remember because and I remember I kept I
was so filthy and full of covered in
hydraulic fluid and whatever right I
couldn't get the soap to soak up
you know it just wouldn't lather yeah
yeah I think I went to a whole bottle of
bar of soap before I finally got cleaned
or what I proceeded sure and I had take
apparently I had taken my uniform and
walked to the shower with the
talisthundo but
around my waist
with shower shoes take in the shower and
I'd thrown my uniform that I had on out
in front of my door and I get back from
the shower and I couldn't get anywhere
near it I had to get a stick to move
so bad
I think we burned them yes and uh
and then I remember getting something to
eat
and then I remember going to sleep and
waking up the next morning and we had to
go to uh
S2 debriefing right and then I had the
afternoon often and I think I went back
and went to sleep
and then uh
I got up next morning went back to the
dispensary and started a hole in
silicone like and so how'd all this
begin with your army career at a 19 year
old you went in yeah uh I was in a North
Hollywood California draft board and
there it was an old area they weren't
there they were really not getting out
too many deferments so I was about to be
drafted so I talked to my father and he
said you know based on my experience and
World War II being in the Marine Corps
he said
1942
he went in he said you know if you're
going to join the Marine Corps that's
one thing but I don't recommend you
being a draftee in the very core
okay
the Navy is a great service don't get me
wrong but I don't I'm not really
thrilled about salt water
yeah you me both
and then uh
not thrilled about salt water
and the Air Force my God somebody had to
look
there was a waiting list to get in the
Air Force I mean it would enlisted wise
right I don't know about Pilots but to
be an enlisted man in the air force
during that time frame this now we're
talking 1960
seventh there was a waiting list along I
mean a couple years or something
the Coast Guard was even worse it was
like somebody said it was a five-year
waiting list at that point
because people were joining them to
thinking they're going to avoid Vietnam
a little bit ago like a lot how these
guys have joined the National Garden
found herself in Vietnam yeah indeed
yeah
so that's how I ended up in the Army and
I I picked the Army because it I think
it settled me first
and the way I ended up in Special Forces
when I was at AIT infantry at Fort
Gordon Georgia
I had gone to basic training at Fort Ord
which I understand has been closed years
ago yes
and uh so
I uh you know how you're in the Army and
that I you know I grew up this is the
60s they call me out of formation told
me you're going out and take a test
okay written test
so I go now and take this written test
well this Sergeant comes in with a Green
Beret on I remember yeah
he's a recruiter
at Fort Gordon pretty special forces yes
and uh
so he said we want you to take this test
well you know you're private in the Army
and you just do what you're told sure
and they and they they and I my dad said
do the best you can if you know they
tell you to do something do the best you
can he said if you screw it up okay but
don't screw it up because you didn't try
right so I took the test
I didn't think anything of it because I
had joined for Airborne infantry sure
unassigned yeah
so I at the end of AIT infantry I get
which I was 11 Charlie Motors right
I get a
sign to jump School parachute School
and I go at the end of parachute school
I got these orders to go to Fort Bragg
they loaded up I think
about maybe 10 of us on a 10 or 12 of us
on a bus and bust is the Fort Bragg
North Carolina
and then I get there and I have to take
another series of tests battery written
tests and they just come out well Rose
you're going to be a medic I said
okay
no it's like yeah
you know I don't know if they were
shortage of Medics because I never
thought I had much of an aptitude for
that kind of thing yeah so I went and
spent the next year see I knew I
couldn't be in medic I knew my
shortcomings I couldn't do it but you on
the other hand so I spent the next what
year and a half sure going through
Special Forces now it's like you
wouldn't believe the requirements no
it says two and a half year course and
it's still the best medics in the world
all special ops whether you're Navy
Coast Guard Air Force go to Special
Forces medical training at Fort Bragg
they do yeah yes sir so anyway which is
great because then you get the benefit
of all the services in that medical
training and stuff sure so anyway I get
uh
I go through the training and I get
assigned the seven Special Forces screw
then uh a year at the 46th company I was
yeah you survived time with the sergeant
Lonnie Holmes yes and a few other
reprobates yeah
Shaw and Weitzel yes and uh
so uh I spent a year in 4600 which I
think really benefited me greatly
because I I learned a lot about dealing
with tropical diseases
and
not combat ones but you know you see an
actual that's weak old it's not been
treated
you know it smells good too oh yes
uh you you you I learned a lot about
Pediatrics
uh which is critical to any green beret
medic and uh because they people used to
bring you children all the time all the
time and then I went to Vietnam to Max
odd and
and we helped my duty I was in the
dispensary every morning
seven days a week
holding sick call you know what really
amazes me they're about three or four of
us and we we have we'd see 300 people
between about seven in the morning and
around 11 12 at noon no kidding oh yeah
you you got a production your sick call
it wasn't that big
could they bring so well see we were
right next to cartoon and we were seen
primarily
we weren't seeing troops no we saw
mostly children and women
uh
or children you know sure you know
that's what we were treating for the
most domestic stuff yeah indigenous and
a lot of it was like oh I don't know you
know
crashes and
pneumonias and
whatever and I think what happened is
you know they bring their kids and then
they get better really quick
so that word gets out so the next you
know today you got ten go see boxy yeah
the next day you got 20 and then you
know yeah and Contin relatively speaking
to Vietnam the uh the next biggest
anything was pleco which was about down
40.
up 14 yeah up 14 clicks yeah 14 no I
mean Highway 14. oh Highway 40 sorry yes
I think it was Highway 14. and I don't
know I was never there a cartoon I I
don't know what life will be too there
were carbon or a big rock there and
um I wonder if it's still there for I
don't know but anyway
um
you saw a lot of that and then you went
to the field and you came back
and uh
but you saw a lot and then of course
we did the you know the local houses
yes of course we we did
yes we
are soon yes exactly
you know it was amazing on a lot of
these uh people that were you know you
could use like penicillins on an
American right and it would you'd
struggle to get that whatever it was
because they've had so much bone pills
but these a lot of the the locals they
never had antibodies
right and they get something and you
give them a shot man you could almost
you know the next day you'd see a
noticeable Improvement
indeed well look uh because of our time
Factor here
um
um I wanted to uh just mention briefly
and not even focus on it
just to say that 28 years later
the Communist News Network also known as
CNN came out and they did a fictitious
story
on tail on Tailwind
that was slanderous
it was error written and it was a
complete insult to every man that was on
it I think it was a complete insult to
anybody that is served in the U.S
military since April 19 1775.
indeed uh it was it was disgusting
uh
you know it's kind of like they should
well one of the reporters said well I
saw the launcher so we know they use
boys and gas and my response was well
you know one we had one five five
millimeter howitzers and eight inch
houses in Vietnam both of those weapon
systems have a nuclear round but that
doesn't mean we had a nuclear round in
Vietnam yeah
and so the fact that we use CS they turn
that around also to make it into GB
right well you know like I said earlier
CS is not a pleasant thing to be around
but it worked on that day and it helped
save your bacon right and um and maybe
you know saved our bacon but you know
maybe in a way how many how many uh
how many North Vietnamese troops got so
overcome by the gas that weren't
yeah they're disoriented enough that
they could not open fire or throw a hand
grenade into the ch-53 or didn't get as
far to toward us that maybe they didn't
get end up getting hurt from the
aircraft that was dropping stuff you
know there's a lot of things you can
think about or carry this sure
so the Communist News Network did this
piece Time Magazine repeated the yeah
they used my fat little face all over
the world as the Peter Arnett
and I there there used to be a a New
Zealander I think he's passed away now
he was in U.S army right they come to
our breakfast is here in Huntsville
every month okay and he said the only
thing about when he left New Zealand we
were so glad that we left New Zealand
because he wasn't even the new
zealanders didn't like Garnett
so
that is case there is litigation there
are suits filed
a lot of people got fired and a lot of
people left the journalism
industry if you will indeed and but more
importantly what I want to move on to
was how your life has been impacted ever
since October 23rd
2017 went at the White House president
Donald J Trump presented you sir with a
medal of honor
for your actions during that mission
uh the first year was bizarre I mean it
was like I mean the phone calls the
letters you know I can't imagine
and the emails
starting with the second year kind of
slowed down third year it's gotten quite
a bit now going into the fourth year
because I'm falling into the history
yeah
uh I am being contacted by mainly
legitimate groups that's not something
uh they're not interested in uh making a
profit off of
this and and tell you a funny story and
this is your Medal of Honor you pointed
to yeah that you received at the White
House and let me also I'd like to say
something about this medal please
any one of those Americans
on that operation
could have been awarded
this it was like
the 16 of us
Drew straws
and I got the short one
because the actions that everybody
Boudreau Smith
uh or just uh mccarlin Adair Orozco the
the things that I saw these men do
over the period of that four days work
where Way Beyond what is expected of a
member of the United States military
I mean there and and then to give credit
to the air Crews
absolutely I mean heroic heroic I mean
day and night flying into any aircraft
with in a kite basically is incredible
so the courage that was displayed
uh the the Marine Corps the Air Force
and the army
there is nothing but Pride
and uh
greatness of all the men involved and I
also want to thank
you know not just the air Crews but
those those guys when those that were
there
making sure that they could refuel
and reload the ammunition on those
aircrafts because my understanding that
the Marine Corps Air Crews were so
exhausted right right
uh that there were cooks and clerks and
everybody else marines that were
volunteering to fly because they knew
the [ __ ] was in the fan that they didn't
care was our army people on the ground
no but they knew that there was a bunch
of Americans down there if they don't
get them out they're not coming home
absolutely and literally we would never
we would we would be among the missing
in action yeah yeah the flag behind you
would be my epithet indeed and the um on
that after that mission there are how
many purple hearts awarded to uh during
that day the special forces have been on
the ground and
my understanding
account that I have
and I have not scientifically verified
this right I can tell you there were 24
purple hearts for the special forces and
my understanding there was another
12 issued for the air Crews
who are wounded in action who are
wounded yeah so a total of 36.
and if all of those Mountain yards have
been U.S troops
uh they would have had the Army
accounting command would have had to put
in another order for purple hearts
because there was not a single Mountain
yard on that operation that wasn't had
some kind of injury from the
yeah and the other thing that you had
was the concern for
um
how many of the indigen were wounded out
of the 120 that went out there more than
60 were wounded that those were the ones
that uh uh that was the number that is
that needed a medics right
but if you talk about
if you if you ask how many I saw
I probably saw more than 60 because
they'd come by and ask for a Band-Aid or
something right
no I'm sure you know deadly serious yeah
like if you're you know if you got
something here and you want to Pat it so
if you're left-handed or right shoulder
or whatever sure so when you fire your
weapon it's not bouncing up against
whatever there and and I can tell you
the bruising
the the effects of you know bamboo yeah
uh one of the things that with me when I
got hit so bad right when I got thrown
up in the air yeah was for a year at
first year Margaret and I were married
Margaret spent oh she said she hates
this but she she said yeah I did it I
would get like boils
and travel
she would either pull out a piece of
metal or a piece of bamboo
it would finally festered come up oh you
haven't went on for a year after oh my
God people never think about that and so
moving something more positive one of
your missions today with the Medal of
Honor Society is education program let's
talk just a little bit about that so
people could be aware of what your
effort there and your dedication to that
Vision today
one of the things that I think is so
important is character development
like there are three Lakes of this
character development I'm not talking
about self-esteem
self-esteem is what what's this one
snowflakes moved
they don't want their feelings hurt
right
the first thing is is education
that's a formal education academics Math
Science History valid history truthful
history English literature that what
helps you make you think all the things
you need to learn in school art music
everything else
then there's the the peripheral
education which is somewhat from
semi-formal to informal which went
through boy scouting or being a member
of various clubs or organizations
you know like baseball or football
learning how to you know sure play nice
with people played a lot of rules play
by the rules uh develop skills eye hand
coordination that comes up
and one of the things you got to
concentrate on yourself
we tell young people you've got to
concern yourself first you need to count
yourself first before you count anybody
else and the reason why and the reason
why is if you don't have that education
and the skills you need you can't help
anybody else
the next thing and that the next leg of
that is
implementing all that education you've
got that's including mentoring
you know if you're 15 and you're an
eagle scout there's a lot of things you
can help with the younger ones if you're
a girl scout the older ones can help the
younger ones you it's picking up trash
when you walk your dog it's
because you want your neighborhood to be
clean and nice
helping the an 86 year old neighbor you
know get their mail without them
struggling with a walker down their
sidewalk or whatever or their driveway
implementing things uh organizing board
ceremonies parties uh
organizing Radio America you know radio
control car organizations learning to
um
to implement all this education
and the older you get the more you learn
the more you can help other people more
and be improve your community sure and
the third thing we don't hear about that
anymore yes civic pride the the second
the third thing rather is to be able to
pass on your culture okay in the United
States what do I mean by culture
the Constitution the United States and
what it stands for
that American flag symbol yes we've had
problems we've had slavery and during
Coral laws but one other nation in this
planet has gone out of their way
with each generation to make things
better
yes we had slavery and it and by the way
the United States did not start in 1619
it started in 1776.
the first year of the war we were trying
to fight for the rights of Englishmen
we were an English colonies of nimrods
and to understand the development of how
we've gone through through Court actions
through peaceful means to improve things
you know through uh changing the
Constitution to make things like slavery
illegal to equal
the 14th Amendment all done without coup
d'etats without having a rifle involved
indeed
and the and we we have his for almost
going on three centuries now passed the
leadership of the country peacefully to
the next person that won the election
yes now you can argue the quality of the
election all you want that's
and the thing is is that I think we
really need to concentrate on ignoring
skin color
we need to operate what Martin Luther
King said the only thing that counts and
that's part of the character development
and education indeed about a person is
the content of their character
it doesn't matter if you're six feet
tall or five feet tall if you're black
white asian or whatever if you adhere to
the principal set down in the
Constitution and the things that
declaration independence and our coats
and our laws
and you believe in the fact that like
Voltaire is alluded to implied but he
really never said it was the fact that
I may not agree with you but I will
defend your right
to say it to the death indeed and those
are the things that I'm talking about
character development education and
where we're working here in Alabama
we've got three school systems
I'm also part of the youth leadership
development program which we've got 95
high schools and we're using a lot of
the character development from the Medal
of Honor Society in that program wow
along with that we've got 27
universities they're supporting our
youth leadership development program
and the purpose is to educate people and
by education I mean tell them the bro
you know you don't tear down a statute
look at that statue and say okay what
does that mean what does it affect you
does it affect you today no but it was
assembled Once Upon a Time what was that
symbol was it a good symbol or bad
symbol if it's a bad symbol explain it
yeah don't don't hide the swastika
you know let's not blow up Buddhist
statues because we're Christians or
Buddhist or Muslims right whatever
um
you know and and this thing about
cultural appropriation oh my God what
Society has an appropriated culture
you know this every place in the world
you know is like
where did alphabets begin
you know if you look at Japan Korea and
China
their alphabets look very similar
because they all have the same root so
is that not cultural appropriation but
it's a good
there's a lot of good uh if you look at
the Roman Empire they were the Great
cultural appropriation appropriators
with roads and built and and aqueducts
and military equipment
you know there's nothing wrong with
using ideas from other cultures in fact
I think that's the greatest compliment
that a culture can
you can come to this country and you
bring part of your culture with you and
then it look people look at it says yeah
that's a great idea
inappropriate yes and then your culture
can play see
that's our piece of the American culture
indeed
and it's a good piece it's a piece that
everybody regardless of where you come
from can use and help better their life
and that's what education is about
amen
and uh as we close out here Mike
any any final thoughts uh particularly
since are first of all what did it feel
like on October 23rd 2017 at the White
House on the podium with the president
awarding you our nation's highest
decoration it was uh when I said you
know I someone ignore because I'm kind
of it's kind of was kind of bizarre and
I don't mean in a bad way no I mean it's
like you become I mean every place I
went in the Pentagon and
and my face was everywhere you know it's
like
indeed it was how did I get here yeah
you walk down a funny story I kept
walking in the Pentagon and they just
kept waiting me through I had an escort
and what I didn't know was the escort
had my badge
and so the the first day I'm in there I
have to go to the bathroom right so I
start walking out to go to the bathroom
because I didn't know you know yeah and
they said wait a minute you got to take
this with her I said what's this this is
your badge badge I didn't know I had a
badge oh yeah I've been carrying it for
a day
so that's one and then the top that out
is every time I go back to the hotel
yeah I have to get a new key well after
the second day the clerk just started
hand anymore because what was happening
is every time I went through security at
the Pentagon it was zeroing out my hotel
room key
the electronic yeah monitor yeah
powerful monitor but I will tell you
this much yes
Mr Trump was he is a gentleman
he was he introduced my wife to the
nation
my grandchildren
and your grandson even had a Moment In
The West Wing did he not oh yeah boy
this kid is he's either I mean he's
either going to be hung or become
president
the uncle
well he
he was standing next to the president
when he was signing the the certificates
and stuff for my medal right they do
that in the Oval Office in with your
family right so afterwards he Pats the
president on the back thumbs up you know
when they come his mother is gone you
know I can just see that so not the
secret secret service yeah yeah so he
walks back around when he pulls on my
sleeve and he says
can I get his offering I said Christian
asked when the man sitting right there
so the president goes like this with his
finger up in the air and his secretary
brings stationary he writes a an
autograph for a Christian he brings him
one of the mega hats and he signs that
oh wow and then uh he says can I get one
for my sister so he gets one for her
sister then Margaret says well can I get
one so he gets one Mark and then he
looks dead at the president
his mother
oh cringing cringy
says
I get one for
oh
the president turns around and the seat
and gets his hands down and looks
straight at Christian right now he says
who's Mrs fizz
well that's my teacher
oh well okay uh so he goes like this he
said why and he says well I'm can you
write it asking her to excuse me for
this week's worth of homework so he did
so we we later on uh yeah Christian did
a video of this
um thing in DC that week yeah and he
showed it was class and we we had it
framed for Mrs Fisk uh but I couldn't
and Mr Trump was smiling you could tell
he was smiling because he I looked at
him he was smiling but he's writing
please excuse you know la la
to get Christian out of homework and I
told him later I said you know if this
doesn't get you out of all that work
you're missing this week
yeah
you bought the farm on this one oh yeah
we're going into the White House and you
know we have this Secret Service in
there's no video or you know or anything
and I look over there with his mother
and a grandmother and there's Christian
with his cell phone on the videos
I mean the kid's Gonna Get Us in jail
but yeah we had it it was there were
funny things like that and there's some
pretty solid moments and indeed and then
um
one of the things is that you know my
wife was escorted into the room on the
arm of the vice president wow that was
cool yeah sure and then I followed the
president
well after the ceremony Zone I stood
back like I was told because we had a
rehearsal and the president's supposed
to go first
and this is tradition he he's the last
one to come in the room and the first
one to leave right
right he looked right at me am I like
this
and I walked out ahead of the president
United States I remember that
and that's that's a tradition that he
broke
and I I mean that kind of thing is just
astounding the little simple acts of
kindness that he's done yeah and uh he
he was very kind of my grandchildren and
you could tell he was enjoying well you
also had a briefing with him with all
the men who were able to attend that
yeah
he was supposed to say a few minutes to
take photographs he spent a half an hour
with us wow and you could see the the
schedulers kind of yeah
but he was having a fun time with uh you
know and it's funny that we have a
photograph of it it looks like it was an
advertisement for Walkers teens and
oxygen bottles you know right because
this is a you know he
I'm sure we're a lot you know basically
physically have been broken
in the service of this country yeah 47
years later
that is not unusual for medal of honors
to be awarded a decade in fact I it's
more of the norm than it is right yeah
yeah what is it Williams got his what a
hundred and how many years 130 years
yeah I hope Mr Obama gave the uh medal
to his descendants of a young man who
was with the fourth uh volunteer feel or
tiller regiment
Rhode Island
on uh and he he received his for action
on July 3rd 1863.
in Gettysburg well and you know that's
my point about this country you know we
make airs we mistakes but we tried to
fix them
you know
unfortunately a lot of times it's
decades after the people that were
injured or ignored or not recognized
sure but at least
we we try
and that's that sums up this country
we have problems we have faults but we
try on a daily basis to fix those things
that aren't right or at least most of us
trying to do indeed I think that's a
great note to close all mine thank you
for coming with us today we really
appreciate it and uh
we also want to say thanks to all the
veterans out there men and women like
you that have served our country who
fought the wars for our country truly an
American hero of someone we look up to
to those of you out there on the front
lines today now we thank you for
Fighting For All of our ideals for
police law enforcement
the border patrol Secret Service
paramedics front line correction
officers
others that are out there every day
serving the better of our country and
Mankind here and thank you to all the
weekend
that do this so that we can live in
safety today
and of course we thank all of our armed
services and for those who didn't come
home we salute you
until next time